hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba what
is your name
jte movie think Jesus Christian last
YouTube you might see JT screen junkies
Collider videos and now here one step at
a time to say led to this this is the
culmination of be on this channel and he
is so good at commentary and that's why
we're gonna watch a mean tweets video
The Avengers you know I've seen it I
would have expected it saw your point of
view he got this far looking like a bug
with buck teeth but here we are
Scarlett Johansson has the emotional
range of a celery I hate white people
why do so many people have a crush on
Sebastian Stan he looks like a potato
he's right that man Winston Duke brought
us hell up top with crack headlights
damn beetle that rhymes a muskrat and a
roach
that's just steal we hated Batista like
it's beer I could follow this page it's
like if you had any party stuff he's
ugly the complete joke non teletoon and
he sucks
Benedict Cumberbatch always looks like
he's had an allergic reaction
oh man to reptiles ever notice chances
are she'll allow me to ask you who
though do you think you are I don't know
maybe I'm gonna just have to Google
myself she's vanished very simply what
kind of the coolest blackest dude in the
galaxy end up with some white meats
right I hope people just want to hate to
hate man how do you get Captain America
I don't know man Oh Rudd thank man is
just pure charisma joy dude so many
people would sleep with Paul Rudd come
on I'd sleep with Paul we'd have a
threesome with Paul Rudd
yeah he got me wet hot and summer the
Paul Bettany when I kind of get cuz he
married Jennifer Connelly and I hate
anybody
you married right yeah I'm kind of
surprised by how a lot of these weren't
that mean I've like I've seen the mean
tweets were like sure Disney was like
don't go to too mean on this one doesn't
like Doctor Strange
I love how Benedict Cumberbatch yeah my
favorite when they actually laugh at it
yeah because a lot of these are just
like weird mean comments like I bet most
of them are just childish no dude
Elizabeth Olsen with the thumbs
my fingers go back can you do that no
that's gross don't joint I'm weirdly
more attracted to you now check this out
[Applause]
people saying these guys are ugly you're
all wrong man all these people are
beautiful that's why they're in the MCU
hey guys subscribe to the rejects nation
quick notification bells as they exist
jte movie thinks where he talks about
jte stuff what is the notification bill
dude because I'm actually starting
people to my channel find this little
belly buttons don't worry JT what they
don't you hit subscribe
they won't get notified unless you hit
the notification belt you work at screen
junkies